hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu mal
wann es Beauty corner heute packen wir
ein Adventskalender aus von
the fora dieser Adventskalender wurde
mir auf tiktok empfohlen ich habe ein
Video von meiner Nichte Soraya bekommen
und sie hat gesagt packt diesen Kalender
bitte aus tschüss ich habe mich nicht
mit den Produkten spoilern lassen möchte
mal schauen ob der wirklich so gut ist
wie die Person gesagt hat dass sie gut
ist
war das Deutsch anyways there the
foreignen Kalender ich kenne so forever
noch aus New York damals hatte ich noch
nicht so eine Ahnung was das sein soll
kelly hat mir gezeigt ich war instant
verliebt weil sie halt diese ganzen
Marken hatten die damals Douglas und so
noch nicht hatten where Beauty Kylie
Jenner Zeug aber scheiße
ich bin kein beauty-experte dafür bin
ich aber ungeschminkt und ich werde euch
die ungeschminkte Wahrheit sagen man
kann schon sagen dass Beauty und
make-up-adventskalender auf dem
Adventskalender mag immer die krassesten
Ersparnisse haben also zahle 100
bekommen für 300 Produkte was hast du
gekostet sofort
ich habe 150 Euro dafür ausgegeben
nach holy Shit also da erwarte ich jetzt
gute Sachen 150 aber der sollen Wert von
395 haben das ist halt krass einfach das
ist krass ich glaube aber die Marken
kaufen sich da ein bzw bekommen die da
super Rabatte dass das halt überhaupt so
angeboten werden kann weil kein anderer
könnte sich das leistenprodukte so
wegzuhauen
was da drin ist
hier vorne sind jetzt die ersten 12
Türchen und da drunter sind die anderen
12 man pack den halt so aus der Box raus
aber was ich glaube sehr schön ist es
wenn man dann die einzelnen Sachen
einfach so auf eine Kommode drauf stellt
vielleicht ein bisschen Deko drumherum
und dann hast du einen tollen
Adventskalender ich bin mir eigentlich
schon ziemlich sicher dass dieser
Kalender sehr gut sein wird und bevor
ich noch weiter sage wie toll dieser
Adventskalender ist dieses Video ist
nicht gesponsert und jetzt alle dieses
Videos nicht gespannt ich finde es halt
schade dass ich euch das jetzt nicht so
hinstellen kann weil ich finde dass man
so ein bisschen netter was klappt dann
halt zu legen den einfach mal so hier
hin natürlich Türchen Nummer eins ich
bin ja ehrlich gesagt ein Geizhals was
so mega Produkt angeht ich benutze gerne
gutes Make-up aber die Preise sind
wirklich manchmal so krass in Türchen
Nummer eins befindet sich eine Natascha
denoner Palette Natascha denoner ich
kleiner Make-up Experte weiß natürlich
dass Natascha denona total toll und
teuer ist sind immer die zwei Tees toll
und teuer wichtig die Farben schreien
Weihnachten und damit werden wir uns
jetzt auch
alleine diese drei Farben Kosten 14 Euro
20 Pinsel wow das ist wirklich stark
pigmentiert ich freue mich gerade total
weil ich habe kein rosa was halt so
wirklich farbintensiv ist und immer wenn
ich so eine Rose Auge machen möchte habe
ich nichts was so guten Effekt haben
gehen wir mal das dunkelrode aus Frank
ich weiß so sieht jetzt wieso oh das
sieht jetzt nicht so toll aus ne Leute
ich kann mich wirklich schminken aber
gerade ist der Wurm drin die Farben sind
mir zu intensiv also wenn man intensive
Farben nicht so mag dann ist es ähm
schwierige vollenden alles mit dem
Glitzer wow oha oha
gut ich liebe diese Palette Türchen
Nummer 2 und clansingbahn vergessen
macht euren Ort klein sind beim Reisen
und man findet nicht auf diese Forderer
Seite eine Ewigkeit später 4 € 65 Nummer
ist wirklich das kleinste Produkt nass
und was ist das
auch so eine Marke die hat nur in jedem
Youtube-Video gesehen alle Beauty
Youtuber hatten immer nass und selbst
konnte sich das nicht leisten aber es
war irgendwie trotzdem schön andere
Leute das Benutzen zu sehen es sieht aus
wie ein Blush muss es ja sein oder 2,5
Gramm kosten 19,95 € 10
ausprobieren würde
das ein bisschen Glitzer mit drin ich
habe das Gefühl die Leute benutzen aber
gar nicht mehr so puder-blush sondern
flüssigen Blush bin aber noch so
oldschool ich kann mich immer so schwer
umstellen nicht eine Sache gelernt habe
dann mache ich das halt so ja also sehr
zart ne ich habe das Gefühl ich muss
drauf drauf machen bin ich so überzeugt
aber da steht nass drauf deswegen will
ich es lieben Nummer vier
oh oh oh der sieht aber schick aus mit
der Farbe macht man an Weihnachten auch
einfach nichts falsch ne das ist die
Weihnachten Fingernägel Farbe die
inoffizielle offizielle
11,95 € in die verlosungsbox ich habe so
viele rote Nagellacke und bevor ich das
jetzt ausprobiere und kontaminiere kann
ich das da hinten in meine Kiste und am
Ende meiner Adventskalender Videos werde
ich eigen verpackt Adventskalender
verlosen also falls du das nicht
verpassen möchtest folgt mir einfach auf
Instagram da wird es dann irgendwann die
Notification geben ich habe auch 150 €
für diesen Kalender bezahlt aber die
Preise die diese Produkte haben sind
schon echt beeindruckend Nummer fünf
zwei Produkte ich flippe aus Augen
Patches surfschild und Eis das ist so
ein Produkt ich habe das Gefühl ja es
bring t schon was wenn man es morgens
benutzt und irgendwie ganz frisch
aussehen will aber so richtig ja weiß
ich auch nicht ob es nicht zwei kalte
Löffel unter den Augen auch tut müssen
was ich meine für mich ist es aber eher
so ein psychologisches Produkt wenn ich
das benutze dann habe ich das Gefühl der
Tag gehört mir ich starte schon richtig
gut rein heute werde ich beautiful
aussehen und bin einfach erfolgreich
stark und schön
nein das Marketing hat bei mir einfach
Früchte getragen 5,18 um sich stark
schön und schlau zu fühlen es ist ein
Nikolaus wir gehen an unseren
Adventskalender und nehmen Türchen
Nummer 6 in die Hand und freuen uns denn
hier wird was ganz besonders tolles drin
sein wahrscheinlich nicht ich glaube sie
kommt sicherlich aus Deutschland und Sie
werden das nicht für den deutschen Markt
optimiert haben und Sie wissen
wahrscheinlich gar nicht das Nikolaus
ist eremis Grinsen
das ist ein Lippenstift oh ich fühle
mich jetzt auch so blöd bestimmt muss
man die ganzen Marken kennen und dann
werden wir alle wieder in den
Kommentaren schreiben soll kennst du das
nicht nee ich bin 30 jetzt ich bin
langsam hinterher
boah jedes Jahr das gleiche
28,95 und ich bin schockiert wenn ich
den nicht ausprobiere bin ich blöd das
ist ein tinted lippenbein das sind meine
30 € gut investiert so irgendwelche
Superkräfte oder sowas sind die Daily
Lippenbalsam also es ist Labello für 30
€, aber mir fällt auf das ist ein
absoluter Highlight für Nikolaus also
vom Preis her ist es bis jetzt das
teuerste gewesen 7 Uhr Zeit ab sofort
jetzt haben wir schon eigene Produkt
hier der Volume extra
ist ab macht deine Wimpern zu krass
künstlichen coolen tollen Wimpern
amazing ich habe jetzt nie gehört dass
Wimperntusche irgendwie gehyped ist oder
super toll aber sie macht einen guten
Job
wow ich habe zurzeit den Loreal
Teleskope und der macht mir viel zu viel
Zeug drauf aber ich will die immer nicht
weghauen bevor ich die nicht
aufgebraucht habe deswegen gebe ich mich
dann da so durch wenn dir den
Unterschied sehen schon schön ich bin
Fan das einzige was so ein Mascara
wirklich durchhalten muss ist den Tag
und dass man halt nicht hier irgendwann
so krümelt oder so schwarze Schatten
bekommt weil das alles runterfällt 13 99
Nummer 8 ich bin jetzt schon ein
bisschen Hype good girl Blush ich kann
mich nicht aus aber ich weiß dass
Carolina Herrera glaube ich gut ist
ja das sind diese Parfüme die
Parfum für diesen Schuh tolles Design ne
also das ist so girly Girl oh das ist
ein sehr sexy durft how I love it und
ich bin echt kompliziert mit Parfum aber
irgendwie oh ich hatte gerade so eine
Erinnerung so einen richtigen Flashback
als ich so 19 war und gerade angefangen
habe in Clubs zu gehen und man sich so
zu performiert hat da habe ich genau
solche Düfte getragen amazing 10,95 €
Make-up Adventskalender machen Spaß
leute
guckt mal was man hier für Geschenke die
ganze Zeit bekommen WoW und jetzt haben
wir ein Make-up forever ehrlich gesagt
Eyeliner
wirklich glaube ich mit Schimmer
oh nein ich mag meine
oh
seht ihr das ich finde es fantastisch 23
Euro 95 das war natürlich einen neuen
drin gefällt mir extrem gut wow der
gefällt mir wirklich sehr gut ich bin
richtig begeistert Nummer 10 und du
musst gehen nein mann ey ich will auch
immer so Kalender nicht so übertrieben
abhalten aber
schöner Stein ist das bitte und dazu
gibt es dieses season die Maske riecht
fantastisch ich will mir gleich diese
glibbermasse in meine Visage klatschen
und dann so schön das Gesicht guaschan
und weil ich habe einen aus Jade aber
der wurde so schnell so stumpf und jetzt
fühlt er sich irgendwie so unangenehm im
Gesicht an und die sind auch voll teuer
wisst ihr wogegen mir dieses bouran
quatschen
Stein massieren hilft ich habe manchmal
Mandelsteine und die sind ja total
unangenehm weil sie riechen halt sehr
unangenehm und ich habe sie nicht immer
aber manchmal merke ich so oh irgendwie
ne ich rieche und wenn ich dann mit dem
Stein so lang gehe und dann so ein
bisschen ja alles hier so in Bewegung
setze dann lösen die sich halt immer so
ein guter Tipp falls ihr auch mit
Mandelstein zu kämpfen hat man hier sind
einfach mal 30 € drin ganz normal Nummer
11 wir sind noch nicht mal bei der
Hälfte angekommen bin schon sowas von
überzeugt hier wieder ein Produkt aus
der Kategorie hat keine Ahnung was das
ist ist es Gehalt kennt man dass
von diesen Adventskalender Videos mein
Schrank ist voll mit Lippenprodukten
aber ich benutze sie auch alle
toller Geruch tolles Gefühl auf den
Lippen ich habe das Gefühl ich esse
gerade eine Kokosnuss 100 % natural ich
glaube das ist einfach nur Kokosfett
also das was man in einem großen Glas
kaufen kann könnte man auch seinen
Finger reinstecken und den machen
Halbzeit Nummer 12
Beauty das ist mir gerade auf dem Tisch
gefallen ich hoffe das ist jetzt nichts
kaputt gegangen wer Beauty Selena Gomez
einer
es war so ganz toll ich
sterbeauty sieht einfach so toll aus
sind diese ganzen neuen Make-up Marke
die einfach so viel Wert darauf legen
das ist hübsch aussieht weil es einfach
eine Rolle spielt wenn man Produkte hat
sie aussehen perfekt Stroh wir machen
jetzt mal ein bisschen was dramatisches
okay
wow
[Musik]
man dieser Kalender ist einfach nur ich
rede mich eigentlich viel lieber auf ne
aber dieser Kalender tolle Produkte wenn
ich diesen Kalender privat bekommen
hätte von Timo jetzt z.B oder mir selber
gekauft hätte ich bin selfmade Girl ich
kann mir selber was kaufen ich will
jeden Tag happy ich wäre wirklich jeden
Tag happy und hätte etwas worüber ich
mich freuen würde es gab bis jetzt noch
kein Produkt drin wo ich gesagt habe
weil sie nicht Digger ich bin jetzt
keine Naomi im Eyeliner mal ne aber so
spitz und so definiert so nach also so
habe ich das lange nicht mehr
hinbekommen
25 Euro 95 ich werde mich sehr an diesem
Eyeliner erfreuen ich weiß aber nicht ob
ich ihn mir nachkaufen würde danke
Celina Gomez danke mein Gesicht ist
jetzt nicht mehr wirklich symmetrisch
das macht aber gar nicht oh wie cool
in Türchen Nummer 13 ist diese blöde
gehypte lippenmaske über Nacht lips
sleeping mask mein Mann hat ja
mittlerweile auch schon die Erfahrung
gemacht dass du überhaupt die Produkte
jetzt nicht immer super geil sein müssen
ne aber sie riecht toll sie sieht toll
aus ich werde sie übernachtet definitiv
benutzen 9,18 € Nummer 14
die Marke kennt man auf jeden Fall was
bist du daily milk folien.com Base
Powder exfolien man hat nasse Hände dann
macht man sich das auf die Hand dann
kreiert man so einen Flüssigkeit und
dann macht man so und das soll
Unreinheiten exfolieten also wegmachen
aber auch wieder designmäßig Top 1 Euro
Programm kostet dieses Zeug das ist
heiße Ware 13 €. habt ihr damit
erfahrung mit der Marke schreibt mir mal
gerne auf die wirklich auch so gut ist
weil ich höre immer von dieser Marke und
sehe sie immer irgendwelchen leben aber
so eine Bewertung ob die überhaupt was
bringt weiß ich nicht habe ich noch
gehört fünf zehn
ich flippe doch aus
ich habe doch gerade noch davon
gesprochen dass die Leute heutzutage
flüssigen Blush benutzen und nicht mehr
hutriegen das ist genauso ein flüssiger
Blush von dem ich gesprochen habe ja
absolut gehypt ich sehe nur noch Leute
sich so Blush auftragen
oh ich geblutet nein Spaß oh mein Gott
ist das amazing ja ich verstehe absolut
warum die Leute das macht das verbindet
sich halt super toll mit dem Make-up das
ist das puderblatt nachdem ich 100 mal
drüber gegangen bin das ist einmal zwei
kleine Tropfen drauf und zwar ich will
es nicht immer sagen aber von Benefit
ist auch alles so teuer ist voll gut von
Benefit ich wünschte einfach die hätten
mich mal auf so eine bene für drei sein
geladen die sind immer auf die Malediven
geflogen nach Japan benefit hat immer so
komplett übertrieben mit ihren Influenza
reisen wo also jeder neidisch drauf sein
kann komm das ist eine Originalgröße ich
flippt doch aus 21 Euro 45 16 super
schwer eine Kerze die riecht interessant
gut perfekt knightsleep Englisch
levender sweet Basel Jasmin ja das ist
wirklich eine abendkerze im Schlafzimmer
sind aufräumen bisschen hübsch machen
Kerze an noch ein Buch lesen so will man
doch jetzt den Herbst verbringen ich
freue mich ehrlich gesagt so krass auf
den Herbst ich konnte damit jetzt nicht
umgehen das schon wieder Sommer wurde
das war mir das war mir zu viel weil
innerlich schon auf Herbst eingestellt
und dann kommt da plötzlich der Sommer
75 Gramm Originalgröße 21,95 € wir
flippen doch aus 100 % natürliche dürfte
natürliche dürfte heißt nicht
natürliches Wachs das ist kein also
außer ich gerade komplett aber das ist
kein hochwertiges Wachs
definitiv nein
den ganzen Tag so weitermachen Türchen
Nummer 17 dachte da steht Christopher
Robin aber da steht Christoph Robin
people also ein Peeling riecht sauber
ist bestimmt wieder ein ganz tolles
Produkt
was excuses wir dachten das ist hier
schon alles Peeling kennen wir das ist
ein Haarpeeling boah einmal die Woche
ein tablespoon ins nasse Haar rein
massieren und dann ausspülen ins nasse
Haare nicht auf die Kopfhaut ins nasse
Haare ich mein Google man hat so
Kalkreste im Haar vielleicht hilft es
dagegen aber seine Haare zu spielen was
kommt als nächstes jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich 60 Nummer 18 viele runde kleine
Döschen sind jetzt hier drin Proteine
politikini Creme Elephant oh die Marke
ist bekannt das ihr benutzt nicht
morgens Politik
ich benutze es nicht morgens was ist
denn los mit euch routini Police pittini
cremig 50 ml kosten 68,95€
also riecht jetzt nicht besonders 20
Euro für diese kleine Probe 19
also ein sehr langen haltbarer
Lippenstift den werde jetzt mal nicht
auspacken in die verlosungsbox packen 10
€ 20 wir sind in den 20ern angekommen
das heißt wir neigen uns dem Ende zu
clarifying Serum husted barrier oh ich
brauche eine boosted barrier ist ganz
kaputt und das soll anscheinend die
Hautbarriere hey das sind doch tolle
also ich weiß auch nicht das sind
irgendwie schöne Produkte 14,95 € bei
den Serien kann ich ja nichts sagen ich
finde sowieso das ist halt immer
Ansichtssache wie gut und häufig man
Serien benutzt um da wirklich eine
Wirkung zu sehen ich benutze manchmal
eins und dann vielleicht wieder nicht
und also man musste halt wirklich sich
damit auskennen und sich mal darüber
informieren was man benutzen sollte und
dafür kann ich x Skin her empfehlen
falls ihr den noch nicht kennt Originals
jawollo und Richards auf mehr ist von
Richards meine lieblings-reihe die gelbe
toll wächst eure 36 Make-up war eher so
am Anfang drin zum Ende gibt es jetzt
hier diese
Produkte Puder Beauty das kennt sogar
ich ein Code wow das testen wir aus ein
Code wow okay hier hatten wir diese
Vorwahl die war ja schon tip top jetzt
kommt die Huda
ja geht so ne na ja nee also die ist
auch gut ja die ist nein also dieser auf
jeden Fall besser als diese aber wenn
man so natürlichen Look haben möchte
dann finde ich diese vor ein bisschen
besser die ist auch schon sehr gut
23,95 €. ja ich meine die ist gut die
ist gut die ist gut wenn ich noch öfter
sage dann glaube ich auch selber ich
finde die toll vorletztes Türchen oh
dieser Kalender infused Herr oil und
wisst ihr was ich daran gerade so geil
finde wenn man am 23 noch so ein
Geschenk braucht wisst ihr so oh mist
ich habe irgendwie für meine Schwester
nichts und oder für meinen keine Ahnung
dann hast du einfach so ein verpacktes
Teil sorry dann kannst du praktisch
vielen Sachen machen die dann einfach
verschenken 100 Milliliter von dem Zeug
hier kosten 76 €, 95 wir haben 20
Milliliter 15 €, 39 da freue ich mich
das will ich mal benutzen meine Haare
finde ich irgendwie ganz trocken und
blöd an in letzter Zeit es ist so weit
es 24 Türchen es ist Weihnachten ihr
seht am 24 so aus wie ich alles anders
geschminkt alles ein anderes Produkt und
dann seht ihr das ist zum Ende noch
ich flippe doch aus
[Musik]
Anastasia Beverly Hills wow die fasse
ich nicht an die werde ich in die
verlosungsbox reinpacken tolle oh tolle
Farben wirklich wunderschöne Farben die
sind nicht günstig wie kann man genauso
bei the fora kaufen 32,95 € 33 €. ich
rechne jetzt mal ganz kurz die Preise
zusammen und dann gibt's das Fazit 356 €
und 16 Cent habe ich rausbekommen aber
ich sehe gerade auch schon wieder dass
ich zwei Türchen nicht aufgeschrieben
habe das kann aber doch nicht sein ich
habe wirklich jedes Türchen das habe ich
nicht ja Leute also ich habe zwei Tücher
nicht und bin bei 356 € man hat 150 €
bezahlt da kriegt man schon 200 €
einfach oben drauf dieser Kalender ist
so toll ich bin komplett Fan ich liebe
fast jedes Türchen ich finde der ist
total gut ausgewogen du hast zwei
Haarprodukte drin du hast ein Parfüm
drin Nagellack ein Blush zweimal Blush
Mascara zweimal Eyeliner da ist wirklich
wirklich alles dabei außer die Sachen
die man halt wirklich nicht dabei haben
sollte wie zum Beispiel Augenbrauenfarbe
weil es ja sehr individuell ist Make-up
Farbe ist sehr wie individuell es ist
ein toller Kalender der ist eine 10 von
10 also falls ihr dieses Jahr euch ein
Make-up Kalender holen wollt ich kann
den sofort auf jeden Fall empfehlen ihr
habt ja gesehen es ist ein toller
Kalender holt euch den dieses Videos
wirklich gespannt seid ich habe keinen
Kontakt zu Theora und wir sehen uns dann
das nächste Mal wieder ich muss jetzt
zum Arzt aber ich glaube vorher ich
liebe das einzige was ich machen muss
diesen Eyeliner ausgleichen oh
ich bin so oh wie geil ist das kann doch
nicht sein schauen nein
bis zum nächsten Mal
ciao